la verdad es que cada espacio que nos
permita difundir en qué situación
estamos trabajando en el país nos parece
muy importante y este es el galardón más
alto que da la sociedad interamericana
de prensa entonces en honor a todos los
compañeros que aún no tenemos ni
siquiera claridad porque fueron
asesinados pues en honor a ellos creo
que es un reconocimiento que que tomamos
con
mucha humildad y con mucho orgullo por
el trabajo que realizado
muy bien más allá de la reparación
simbólica que este premio puede
significar qué opina usted sobre las
acciones del gobierno hasta ahora cree
que si se está obrando para proteger a
los periodistas en méxico
no sinceramente no lo creo lo que ha
habido es un discurso que no baja en
contra
permanentemente del trabajo periodístico
ha habido una apertura desde el lado de
la subsecretaría de gobernación
encargada de los defensores de derechos
humanos y los periodistas no ha habido
mayor presupuesto no hay claridad en las
investigaciones
ha habido sí la detención de varios
actores
de los asesinatos sin embargo no
conocemos el móvil ninguno de los casos
no de estos 13 que estamos hablando hoy
sino siquiera de anteriores entonces no
vemos ningún ningún cambio al respecto
el presidente tiene un discurso que es a
ratos contradictorio entonces en una
mañana dice que lo que hay que hacer es
darle seguridad social a los periodistas
y entonces abre una inscripción para que
los periodistas independientes tenga
seguridad social muy bien pero no tienen
nada que ver con la protección durante
nuestro desempeño en nuestro ejercicio
periodístico bien y finalmente le quiero
preguntar precisamente por esos desafíos
de defender la libertad de prensa que
deben ser atendidos en méjico donde hay
por ejemplo territorios que están
dominados por el narcotráfico y por la
corrupción
y
existen una serie de mecanismos que
nosotros mismos vamos tomando a título
personal a título de empresa digamos
donde corremos cada vez menos riesgos
porque no se trata tampoco de ser héroes
y no queremos sumar más números a este
número que ha superado cualquier
expectativa lo cierto es que para poder
hacer eso hay espacios y hay zonas que
están ya totalmente silenciadas y donde
ya no publicamos nada porque no hay la
mínima garantía de que al publicarlo
nosotros estemos protegidos y son varios
los estados del país en el centro del
país
estamos hablando de
guanajuato al norte de tamaulipas al sur
de michoacán son zonas donde los
reporteros ya no van ya no reportan lo
que está pasando ahí no no se genera
información firmada por ellos por miedo
a las represalias que ésta pueda tener